it's time for roses and Rosie oh you
guys I'm so happy what a 24 hours it has
been my emotions my moods have gone from
low lows to high lies because we've been
through a lot everybody
first we had the most emotional scene
ever and now it's been the wildest 24
hours ever in bachelor history so let's
get right to it i'm lauren zima thank
you guys for being with me all season
long as we now finish out our Ian Lions
like season of The Bachelor what I will
remember about this season everybody is
all of this the women so let's get to it
tonight was the after the final rose
conclusion it had its own night this
year and God it just felt like we went
through so much like it was like we
wouldn't throw the Oscars or something
all the different emotional film moments
we had three billboards outside ebbing
Missouri billboard there are billboards
the shape of water the war Dunkirk
the darkest hour and luckily ladybird I
want you to be the very best version of
yourself that you can be oh yes spoiler
alert if you haven't heard that
coopering is our new bachelorette I got
what I wanted
thank God because I was put through
enough you know what after all we've
been through drink every time you were
happy tonight so we go back to the fact
that Arie broke up with Becca Apple to
go after Lauren starfish and he goes
after Lauren pretty quickly and she
gives him a big hug and really embraces
this I was really surprised
Linds again we're seeing more sadness
for Becca sadness on a plane sadness at
her house Anna's in front of her laptop
it's just not fair
Ari's back with Lauren B she doesn't
seem to mind he tells her that the last
month and a half was miserable the
hardest month now wait doesn't seem fair
to Becca I choose you every day from
here on out and Lauren
takes him back away do you think that
you're 100% over Becca yes 1000% I
choose you
I'll get to it today like I was making a
safe decision for my future I was also
interested in how Lauren and our ease
conversation about why he proposed to
Becca just didn't really seem to yield
any real answers which is pretty much
informed with what we've been dealing
with you know like Ari told Lauren I saw
a little doubt in your eyes use your
words guys if we've learned nothing else
this season it's to use your words
do you think that you're 100% over Becca
yes 1000% this guy moves pretty fast
then we cut back to the live audience
and our girls are women Becca m CN
Fleming a Caroline Lenny T abou then
Kendall um her in the crowd yes yes yes
to support their girl and Becca M
supports her and I quote re is just not
a genuine person he just wants to say
whatever he needs to say in front of the
person in front of him to get what he
wants I think he's an incredibly
manipulative person it's ridiculous
Becca I'm good a paradise girl I can't
wait you know at first we called re not
Peter but now I'm just gonna call him
not Becca M says nope that Lauren gets
out of those as soon as possible well we
know she's not going to but she also
says don't get mad at Lauren B because
you know she's just thinking that re
came after her in the face of adversity
please welcome Becca Wow so Becca kufran
comes out looking like a glowing Wonder
Woman you're stronger than this then
that's another movie reference for you
JC he noticed she looked like Wonder
Woman and she is just so gracious maybe
almost too gracious without she handles
this re thing because she reveals that
she did not know that our we got in
touch with Lauren B and that we have
looked at houses together he moves
pretty fast
that wasn't personhood even faster right
the end of this she even hugged him when
he came out so Ari doesn't have a lot of
good explanations at one point he kind
of blames their breakup on Becca working
that wasn't easy for me you were working
and then he says that he regrets
proposing and where did you the pressure
of being the bachelor I have no excuse
for that he owns it he apologizes this
is what we all knew he needed to do
does it change how you feel about him
let me know in the comments guys okay
knowing that there's a time line and
having to make that decision on that day
but you always have a choice and you
didn't need to make that choice it's Ari
no you didn't have to propose okay
you're a grown 36 year old man and you
can make your own choices and you did a
couple of them okay
have the most respect for her be
committed to her so Becca tells Ari that
he needs to commit to Lauren the subtle
shade girl and Ari says that at the end
of the day I'm just trying to sort out
what's best in my life emphasis on the
my my life 1,000% to have my fairytale
ending
it's and it was way more difficult than
I thought it would be I don't have a lot
of sympathy Ari notice I'm still
drinking guys cuz I'm still happy cuz
things get good okay so Lauren B comes
out and I gotta say she looks good and
Becca's facial reaction to when she
comes out as good and Lauren says that
she and Ari have just been waiting for
this moment so that they can be happy
and be a normal couple go and dude no
I'm a couple thing and again you know
more questions here because Lauren says
that Ari reached out on New Year's Eve
first which I told you guys that I knew
from a source and then she says that Ari
had to DM her on Instagram which he
seems to love to do another
oscar-nominated movie the post because
production couldn't give him her number
that's not true check out my interview
with ABC executive Robert Mills it's
over DT online.com shameless plug when
he explains all the behind the scenes
you guys on the break-up that was caught
on camera on how he feels about the fact
that there's been some backlash about it
and it's really great insult
okay so they both sit in a crazy wave
made our love stronger Dunkirk I don't
think people understand the gravity of
this we do Ari we do do you you were
engaged to someone and again you guys
the highs and lows so many emotions so
far we've had sadness betrayal anger a
bit of elation and now we're gonna get a
whole lot of WTF
Chris Harrison said he did not see this
coming I don't know how that's possible
but Ari proposes Becca M's face says it
all are you Lauren B save it after this
a little bit I don't blame you so good
get out like you didn't do last night
get out it's an oscar-nominated movie
also so now we can really get happy
everybody it's my honor to introduce the
new bachelorette Becca Becca kufran is
announced as the Bachelorette
yes I'm so happy you guys I wanted this
to happen I don't want her story to be
that the not affected her so Becca is
gonna write her own story and I love the
way that they ended this episode because
they made it about the women Chris
Harrison brought up all those gals on
stage they were clutching each other in
the audience they were cheering and
screaming for Becca and he said that
this show is really about female
friendships yes that's the love we need
yes yes yes this made me very excited
for this season of The Bachelorette
premiering May 28th on ABC although I am
glad we're gonna get a little bit of a
breather cuz I'm exhausted
we're tired that's an emotion too is
tired guys I mean between minutes
Bachelor Wonder games bones will
two-part finale okay so they pull the
Rachel Lindsay and we meet a few of
Becca's first guys I'm gonna breeze
through them real quick first we had
[Music]
Lincoln like the president but he's
British so he could be the king if he
treats our queen right okay he calls
Aria wanker then we have chase chase you
better chase our girl she deserves it
we've got some guy with a banjo hope you
make her heart sing then we have Darius
don't be nefarious he did apologize for
his gender which I appreciate and last
subdued with the horse always names
Blake Blake you better take your time
and make sure you feel good about your
decisions okay do the damn thing but
again first let's take a breather
because frickin tired oh my gosh Chris
also asked Becca what she's looking for
in a man and she said loyalty and that
got a lot of laughs just somebody who is
loyal who can make me laugh so everybody
what a season in that the first 90% of
it was what it was and I want to say
again that I really tried really hard to
like and support Ari but then the last
24 hours have been what they've been so
you know he's the nut and Becca is what
we've got I'm so excited for her to be
the new bachelorette you guys but again
that season does not premiere until May
28th I want to know what you thought of
this finale please let me know in the
comments below
were you blown away by our E's proposal
or did it seem perfectly insane after
what we've all been through do you think
Ari and Lauren will make it well guess
what we have a new interview with a
certain someone from Ari's past that's
going up at ET online comm check that
out and most importantly I love you guys
so much I so look forward to reading
your comments every week
JC does too and he's the best so we do
not want to part ways he is my work
husband I adore him so we have been
editing this amazing video called spill
in the royalty every Friday it goes up
on our YouTube channel and while we
don't have bachelor nation we have a
different kind of love story it's about
the Royals other kings and queens so
check that out every Friday on e t--'s
youtube channel please and stay in touch
with me in between seasons I love you
guys so much thank you so much for
watching
JC get in here just like Chris Harrison
made the girls
get in there out of nowhere and it was
so unplanned and you know live TV yay
I'm so surprised
do you see you have to say bye like I do
you ready three two one
[Music]
tired guys go asleep
it's been a long season winter games The
Bachelor season it was critiqued as the
most boring ever but trying asleep here
at the office all I do is cover the
patch ler I love you Kay good night